Cloud Code is now a 24/7 AI employee,
which means that it is always Cloud Code
o'clock. And that might be the nerdiest
thing I've ever said. Anthropic has
finally done it and launched scheduled
tasks natively for Cloud Code, which
means every single process, every single
skill, everything you've been building
and using inside of Cloud Code just got
10 times more powerful. And they
literally could not be easier to set up.
So in today's video, I'm going to show
you exactly how they work and tell you
everything important that you need to
know about them. Let's not waste any
time and get straight into it. So here I
am in Cloud Code in the Cloud Desktop
app. Now right now you do need to be
using the desktop app in order to access
these scheduled tasks. Now this
scheduled task feature came out about a
week or two ago in Cloud Co-work. As you
can see, it's basically the exact same
thing. You could create scheduled
automations. But now they finally
brought it to Cloud Code and there's a
few ways that you can set them up. The
first way is you go over here to the
schedule tab and you just click on it
and you can see right here, run tasks on
a schedule or whenever you need them,
type  schedule in any existing
session to set one up. So those are the
two ways. You can either click right
here, new task. You can give it a name,
a description, give it a prompt. You can
choose the model you want it to run on.
You can choose the mode to run on and
you can also select the folder. And then
finally, you just say, "Hey, I want this
to run every hour, every day, every week
at this time." Boom. You now have a
scheduled automation. So that cron would
basically fire off, the session would
start up, and then the agent would read
the prompt, it would go through your
files, it would work in your project, do
whatever it needed to do, and then after
it's done, it would just stop. And the
huge unlock here, which is so exciting
to me, is that this isn't a
deterministic workflow. And so there's
some good there and there's some bad
there. good news is that you can
completely control it. And what I mean
by that is if you've been following some
other Cloud Code videos I've done in the
past, we build either like a Python
script or a TypeScript and that is the
actual automation and that is
deterministic logic code. Meaning that
will always happen, step one, step two,
step three. If there's an error, it
can't fix itself. It just errors and
then we get notified. But this isn't
just a Python script. This is Cloud Code
agent running the same exact way it runs
when you talk to it. And that's why this
is so exciting because Agentic Workflows
are self-healing and they can read
everything in your entire project and
use all your tools. So, as you guys
know, you tell it to go do something and
it starts trying. If it runs into an
error, it doesn't just come back and
say, "Eh, I tried." It says, "Okay,
here's the error. Let me try three other
things and then after I see which one of
those three other things work best, I'm
going to update myself so that I never
run into that error again." So, now you
are no longer the bottleneck and these
skills and these workflows can actually
get better and better over time
automatically. But, the other important
thing to remember here is if you do want
it to be more deterministic and you want
more control, you can do that. Because
you could literally have it just execute
a script and that's the whole scheduled
task and it just is completely
deterministic that way. So, how do you
go ahead and start creating some
scheduled tasks? Well, here you can see
one I have is called morning coffee. So,
I've showed this one off before in a few
other videos, but basically every single
morning, I would open up my Cloud Code
and I would say, "Hey, run morning
coffee." Which would help me plan my
day. It would look at my commitments, it
would look at the projects and help me
catch up on what the team's up to. But
now, this can actually just run
automatically at 6:00 a.m. every
morning. And literally all that I did to
set this up was I said, "Take a look at
my morning coffee skill. I would like to
turn this into a scheduled task that
goes off every morning at 6:00 a.m. Help
me get this set up." It read the skill,
it complimented me on the skill, and
then it asked me one question about it,
and then a minute later, my skill that I
run every morning is now automated. And
if you've never used Cloud Code in the
desktop app, don't worry, it's super
easy. You can basically pull in, you
know, a GitHub repo or a different
folder and you can be working in the
exact same project that you're used to.
So, right here in a new session, I just
asked it, "What skills do you have in
this project?" And it came back and
said, "Hey, here are all the active
skills. We've got content creation,
we've got research and intelligence,
we've got visual diagrams, operations,
and meta." And now, any of these skills
I could just say, "Okay, cool. Turn that
into a weekly automation." All right, so
there are a few limitations though. The
first major gotcha is the fact that your
laptop has to be on or your computer has
to be on and the desktop app has to be
open. So, if you turn off your computer,
that automation will not run. And the
good news is, let's say you had a task
for 7:00 a.m. and you wake up at 8:00,
you turn on your computer, Cloud Code
would actually check back 7 days and see
any scheduled task that it missed and
then would catch up and it would run
those. Obviously, that's not perfect
because some of those may be
time-sensitive, but it is cool that it
has that ability. Now, what are some
other things to think about? Well, the
first one is that this thing is now
running without your supervision. And
ideally, it's not going to stop to ask
you questions because then what's the
point of having it automated? So, that
means you want to be looking at your
permissions to make sure that it can't
actually go off the rails and do
anything like maybe make a major change
to your GitHub repository or go off and
delete things. And you can take care of
that by changing your local settings in
that project, which you could just say,
"Hey, I want to make sure that you never
delete things. How can I put this in
your settings? You know, deny a bash
command that does any deletes or
removes." And it will help you figure
that out. I've got a video coming about
this. I will tag that right up here once
that is live on YouTube. These are also
stateless. So, basically, every time
that you run one of these, it's going to
throw it in a new session. So, right
here, I did a test run of my morning
coffee. Here's the actual task itself.
And then when I open this up, I will be
able to see every run. And every run is
going to be fresh and it's not going to
have context of what happened on the
previous run. And the other thing, of
course, is that if you didn't put in an
API key or if there's literally
something that it can't do because it
needs your permission, it's going to
stop. So, what I'd recommend is as soon
as you create a new task, just run it
manually and make sure that it can go
through all of the steps without
oversight. Otherwise, what's going to
happen is it's going to pause and it's
going to ask you for permissions to do
this and permissions to do that. Now,
sometimes it's a good thing that they're
stateless and that they don't have
shared memory, but sometimes you might
want them to. And that would be kind of
part of this whole self-improving thing.
So, here's how I imagine the
self-improving loop working. So, first
of all is fixing the actual script. So,
you can have in there the fact that if
it errors, edit your own code and make
sure you're fixed. The second layer is
the prompt. So, if you realize that
there's an opportunity to improve this
prompt, rewrite it and now you have a
new prompt. And then the third one is
potentially having a log for memory,
whether that means every single run you
put some sort of like status of what
that run did or maybe you just have a
file that you overwrite so that every
time when the new agent wakes up, it can
look at the log and say, "Hey, this is
what previous agent just did. Now I need
to run." So, there's lots of ways that
you can kind of tweak these scheduled
tasks to fit your use cases better. And
once again, because they have the
context of everything in that project,
they're going to be super powerful. They
can look at any file that you want them
to. So, that's what my brain immediately
went to, but I wanted to see what Claude
Code thought. So, I asked it what it
thought the most optimal strategy was to
make these improve and make sure they
have the right context. So, what it
thought of was a lean strategy where you
have one file per task. So, basically
every single time the agent runs, it
would overwrite this file with
information like, "Here's the last run.
Here's how long it lasted. Here's what
happened. Here's what I did. Here are
known issues." and things like that. And
this is better than an append log in
some scenarios because like I said
earlier, if you run an automation a
thousand times, then you might have a
thousand append logs. But then what's
cool is the actual structure of your
prompt. So, when you're creating a new
task right here, the way that you prompt
it, you could basically say, "Okay,
before you actually do your job, go
ahead and read this file, which is
basically the last run." And then you do
your main task. And then after you're
done with the task, overwrite that file
with any current issues or status or
anything that you found that might help
the next agent. So, obviously I'm going
to be playing around with different
structures of having context shared
between these different, you know,
tasks, but that's just something that I
thought would be really, really cool.
So, another thing I wanted to talk about
is because this is in the desktop app
and because this is running on a
schedule, how do you want to get
notified that that scheduled task has
been done? So, the desktop app does have
notifications, but they're not super
great. At least it wasn't making any
noise and it wasn't capturing my
attention. It's cool that everything
gets organized over here. So, as you
have more tasks, you can see them all
and it's organized. But, what you can do
is you can add a hook so that every time
you actually get a sound. So, what I did
is I set up a hook so that every time a
Claude Code session finishes, I get a
notification. So, listen to this.
So, that was like kind of the default
Windows little sound. You can change
that. But, that's really helpful because
I could be working and I could forget
that a scheduled task might go off and
then I get that noise. But, the other
thing I would recommend is in the prompt
of the actual skill itself, maybe just
at the bottom say, "Hey, once this is
done, just shoot me a Cloud Code message
and say that this happened." And that's
probably what I'm going to set up for
all my scheduled tasks. And if you're
curious about setting up hooks,
literally just say to Cloud Code, "Set
up a hook. I want you to play a sound
every time you finish talking to me."
And it will do it in like a minute. And
the last thing I was curious about is
the fact that we're limited to the
desktop app.
Now, Anthropic is shipping like crazy,
so I'm sure in a week or two that this
is going to be open in the terminal and
in the IDE extensions and stuff like
that, too. But, for the moment, it's
only desktop app.
And basically why is because all of the
actual like cron logic and that kind of
metadata lives in the desktop app, even
though the actual files live in your
computer. They live somewhere where
terminal or your VS Code, Cloud Code
could actually see it. So, I was
interested in that and I said, "Are you
able to see my scheduled task for
morning coffee? It runs at 6:09 and
here's where it lives because it lives
kind of in this global folder path right
here." And it can see it, right? Because
it just exists as a file. But, what it
can't do is it can't create new
scheduled tasks because it can't
actually touch the cron that the desktop
app of Cloud Code sets up. But, what it
could do is it could edit it. So, it
could improve it, it could make changes,
but it can't create them or like run
them. Now, that's actually not a huge
deal to me right now because I usually
work in VS Code, but I can just have the
desktop app open and I can just leave it
open in the background while I've got my
computer on and all of my scheduled
tasks will still be running. And so, now
that Cloud Code is so powerful on its
own, it can actually like do things in
the browser as well, I truly think we're
getting to that point where you can
automate anything. So, I'm going to go
ahead and stop talking. What you need to
do now is go learn how to set up your
project and create your own executive
assistant to become way more productive
and start to schedule some stuff. Go
ahead and watch this video right up
here. So, hopefully I'll see you guys
over there, but that is going to do it
for today. So, I appreciate you guys
making it to the end. And if you enjoyed
the video or you learned something new,
please give it a like. Helps me out a
ton. And I'll see you all in the next
one. Thanks, everyone.